I'm frigging married down and I got the
best wife in the world she supports me
through so much I'm really honored to be
your husband okay there's no denying it
Justin Bieber is the freakin cutest when
it comes to talking about wife Haley and
we should expect a whole lot more
because the Biebs basically wrote his
entire new album changes about her you
know this is an album I wrote in the
first year of our marriage you know so
it's like it's so fresh and there's you
know there's no there's so much more to
learn about commitment and you know
building trust and foundation I'm just
I'm looking forward to continuing to
build and make music that's gonna
reflect that talk about goals I love
them
Justin's new interview is for Apple
music and he's also getting candid about
making new record and the obstacles he
went through I was like dealing with a
lot of fear a lot of like um just was
afraid of like at that point just even
the process what am I gonna talk about
again you know is it gonna be received
you know I'm starting to compare with
other artists the process seemingly
turned out to be pretty therapeutic for
him though it's almost like we need to
run towards the the pain and run towards
the hurt rather than run away from it I
think you get kind of healing when it
comes to that
justin has been really vulnerable lately
also sharing a ton in his youtube
docu-series about his life and yes more
Haley since I was young I always like
wanted to be married I always wanted a
family that was always high on my list
and I have this thickest chick in the
game she's so awesome it all happened
really fast and kind of all at once but
you know him and I have known each other
for so long that there was a part of it
that didn't feel scary but it's just
such a big life decision that
it it was just it was so much emotion
all one time but if you want even more
Justin
have no fear he's already thinking about
what's next
I'm excited about this but I'm just like
there's so much more there's so much
deeper levels I'm excited to go to which
is fun you know it gives me something to
look forward to I think in the past I
was so caught up in all of like the bad
things in my life that I I just I wasn't
able to really take take a second and
really appreciate all the all the little
things but yeah I'm excited it's gonna
be it's gonna be changes is out now it's
his first album in nearly five years
since purpose I felt like I lost my
purpose for a while I felt like I didn't
I wasn't I wasn't chasing after what I
knew I won I was purpose is such an
important thing in life and I just
wanted to use my platform to tell people
that I guess all right guys that's it
for today go listen to changes let us
know what you think and for more on
Justin and make sure that you stick with
all things et until next time I'm Katie
craft and bye for now
[Music]